this video was made possible by
curiositystream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science for just 14.79
and get access to both curiosity stream
and nebula for a year
sickle cell disease is a cruel genetic
disorder that produces a defective form
of hemoglobin
the protein needed by red blood cells to
carry oxygen and deliver it to the body
the defective hemoglobin deforms red
blood cells into irregular
sickle-shaped forms these cells often
block the bloodstream
causing organ damage and sometimes
extreme bouts of pain
for one sickle cell patient victoria
gray the disease has been crippling for
her
entire life much of her life has been
punctuated by trips to the emergency
room due to the pain
with life and career ambitions
interrupted or put on hold
the sickle shaped cells have damaged her
heart and many patients with sickle cell
don't live beyond middle age
strokes or heart attacks are a constant
threat
around a hundred thousand people in the
u.s live with this disease
it is the most common inherited blood
disorder and affects
millions around the world and it is
notoriously hard to treat
some patients can get help from drugs
and others sometimes undergo risky bone
marrow transplants
but for many these treatments are not
enough to get rid of the constant burden
of the disease
so when victoria gray was exploring the
possibility of getting a bone marrow
transplant
her doctors instead suggested something
different in fact something profoundly
different
to try to treat her disease she jumped
up the chance
and would become the first patient in
the u.s with a genetic disease to get
treated with a revolutionary gene
editing technique using crispr
and now one year later it seems to be
working better than
any doctor could have guessed the
billions of genetically modified cells
doctors infused into her body
appear to be alleviating virtually all
the complications of her disorder
so what happened inside victoria gray's
body that has left her almost completely
free of the symptoms of her disease
is the promise of crispr as a medical
revolution starting to become realized
to understand how crispr is used today
let's go back to the beginning of its
story
when crispr was first discovered in 1987
the researchers didn't really even
understand what it is that they had
found
while investigating a particular gene in
e coli
they noticed an interesting pattern in
the dna surrounding it
five identical sequences each composed
of 29 bases
these repeat sequences were separated
from each other by 32 base blocks of dna
called spacers which each had a unique
sequence
the scientists wrote the biological
significance of these sequences
is not known over the next decade these
repeating patterns were found in many
different microbes
eventually these patterns were given a
name clustered regularly interspaced
short palindromic repeats
crispr for short but scientists still
didn't know what they were for
but certain observations about them
started emerging
they were always next to specific
enzyme-producing genes
labeled as crispr-associated genes or
cast genes
cast genes encode enzymes that can cut
dna
but at the time no one knew why they did
so or why they were always next to the
crispr sequence
soon scientists noticed something else
about these dna sequences
that the crispr spacers the variable
sequences in between the repeating
sequences
looked a lot like viral dna and with
this revelation
the purpose of the crispr sequences
started to become clear
that these repeating patterns are a
weapon that the bacteria were using
against viruses
when a virus infects a bacteria it
injects its genome
into the cell if it is a previously
unseen virus
a new spacer is derived from the virus's
genome and is incorporated into the
crispr sequence
the spacers are essentially a history of
old infections
so the bacteria won't be infected again
the crispr sequence is then transcribed
creating short crispr rna molecules
and those repeating palindromic
sequences their palindromic nature means
that these sequences in the crispr rna
can fold in on themselves
creating a hairpin structure the crisper
guide rna then binds with the matching
viral dna
the cast enzyme then cuts and destroys
the invading viral genome
with the hairpin structure helping the
cast enzyme to cut exactly where it's
supposed to
and with a broken genome the virus can
no longer replicate itself
and the infection comes to a halt when
scientists realize that these microbes
are effectively programming their
enzymes to seek and destroy specific
sequences of dna
the significance of the discovery
started to sink in
this could be used as a tool in the past
researchers had been able to use
restriction enzymes to cut up dna
but this did so in an indiscriminate way
the crisper cast system instead
could make precise cuts giving rise to a
whole new
area of science what we now know as gene
editing
crispr technology allows genetic
material to be added removed or altered
at particular locations in the genome
much like hitting ctrl f on your
keyboard finding a word in your document
and deleting changing or replacing it in
order to harness the power of crispr in
the lab
scientists first design and synthesize
short guide rna molecules that match the
sequence of a gene they want to edit
usually about 20 base pairs long then
like in the targeting step of the
bacterial system
this guide rna shuttles the gas enzyme
usually the cas9 enzyme
to the intended dna target the cas9
enzyme then makes a cut across
both strands of the dna at this stage
the cell recognizes that the dna is
damaged and tries to repair it
scientists can use the cell's own dna
repair machinery to add or delete pieces
of genetic material
or to make changes to the dna by
replacing an existing segment with a
customized dna sequence
and this brings us to victoria gray and
her sickle cell disease treatment
while sickle cell is indeed a genetic
disorder her treatment did not involve
going in and deleting or changing the
genes that lead to the disease
instead scientists found a way to almost
completely alleviate the symptoms
the treatment called ctx001
tackles the disease by boosting the
production of fetal hemoglobin
hbf a type of hemoglobin that is present
at birth
but then stops being produced the idea
is that restoring the production of
fetal hemoglobin can compensate for the
defective hemoglobin produced
by sickle cell patients to do this
doctors first harvest stem cells from
the patient's bone marrow
then the crispr cast 9 components are
delivered to the cells
where they then create a deletion in the
gene bcl-11a
which encodes a transcription factor
that normally represses fetal hemoglobin
synthesis
this breaks the gene and allows the
cells to resume making the protein
billions of these modified stem cells
are then re-infused into the body
they won't replace all of the existing
stem cells but if enough of them
successfully
implant and start producing the needed
protein then the treatment will be
effective
doctors hoped after the treatment that
20 of the hemoglobin in victoria gray's
body would be fetal hemoglobin
but the results have far exceeded
expectations
one year after the treatment about 46
of her hemoglobin is now fetal
hemoglobin
additionally 81 of her bone marrow cells
now contain the genetic modification
needed to produce the fetal hemoglobin
protein
indicating the edited cells have
continued to survive
in her body for an extended period
gray's life before the procedure was a
constant cycle of dozens of blood
transfusions and hospitalizations every
year
and now after the experimental procedure
those numbers have been brought to zero
she hasn't had any pain attacks
emergency room visits
or needed any blood transfusions since
the procedure
and while gray was the first patient to
receive this experimental treatment
she was not the only one patients with
beta thalassemia have also received
ctx001
to restore fetal hemoglobin production
their blood disorder causes them to not
produce
enough normal hemoglobin but gene
therapy in several of these patients
have left them no longer needing blood
transfusions for months now
so is this a cure for these blood
disorders not exactly
but gene therapy like this can
potentially prevent many if not all of
these diseases complications
and the change to these particular
patients lives can't be overstated
however the treatment is not without its
downsides
just like for a typical bone marrow
transplant recipients of the ctx001
treatment
have to undergo chemotherapy to
eliminate their own bone marrow
to create space for the injection of
modified stem cells
and just like the chemo for cancer this
comes with grueling side effects
fatigue nausea mouth sores loss of
appetite
hair loss it is not trivial gene therapy
like this is not the same as taking a
pill or a drug
it's more like getting an organ
transplant and much like cancer
treatment it will not come
cheap and even though the results from
these studies have been extraordinarily
promising
there are many questions that are still
to be answered
will the treatment keep working for
months or years to come
will it help these patients live longer
is it safe in the long term
and will there be any unintended side
effects
while these questions do remain it is
impossible not to feel optimistic when
hearing about these extremely positive
results
and these blood disorders are just one
of many things that crispr has begun to
tackle
scientists have started researching
crispr to reverse genetic blindness
muscular dystrophy cystic fibrosis and
even cancer
and even though gene therapy treatment
is expensive crispr technology
is in general cheap to test in the past
it might have cost
thousands of dollars and weeks or months
of fiddling
to alter a gene using old school
knockout techniques
now it costs in the hundreds of dollars
and takes just a few hours
there is still much much research to be
done and scientists are just scratching
the surface of what is possible with
this technology
we can't yet know the exact effect that
crispr will have in our futures
but it is going to be huge
science has progressed towards a much
better understanding of genetics
but there is still so much we don't know
in many ways
our genes are a book that can be read to
determine our destinies
leading to our good health or sometimes
our unfortunate illnesses
but scientists are becoming more aware
that dna doesn't explain everything
and that our environments and our
experiences play a greater role in how
our genes are expressed than previously
understood
if you want to learn more about how
environmental factors can determine
which genes are turned on and off
then you should watch our genes under
influence on curiosity stream
it's a 50-minute in-depth film that
explores how identical twins with the
same dna can be physically different
how generations of plants can be
physically modified without changing the
dna sequence at all
and how epigenetics shapes our biology
more than you might realize
curiosity stream has thousands of high
quality documentaries like this one
about everything from genetics
technology space or
nature there are even a handful of david
attenborough documentaries which if
you're like me
you know are obviously the best ones and
to make it even better
curiosity stream has partnered with
nebula which is the streaming platform
created by me and over
a hundred fellow educational youtube
creators
it's a place where we can express
ourselves completely freely and openly
without worrying about the sometimes
restrictive youtube algorithm
real engineering series the logistics of
d-day is a prime
example of the content you can find
there a series that can talk about the
realities of war without getting
demonetized by youtube for doing so
nebula allows us to take our time
producing content
and open so many creative doors because
of this there is a range of awesome
content you can find there
long form documentaries by creators like
wendover productions
and other nebula original series by
creators like polyphonic tom scott or
minute earth
so if you sign up for curiositystream
curiositystream.comrealscience
you'll get a subscription to
curiositystream and a subscription to
nebula for now just 14.79 a year
26 off the usual price by signing up
you're not just supporting this channel
but all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you would
like to see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you